[Música]
boa tarde
antes de vir para cá eu fiz uma prática
que eu costumo fazer
desde que eu sou pequena que é de ouvir
desde pequena
desde que sou criança que é de ouvir uma
música antes de algum momento desafiador
ou alguma coisa que vai mexer comigo
e essa música ela me faz sentir emoções
à flor da pele assim ela me faz me dá
arrepios ela me dá bem estar e aí eu
fico pensando o tanto de coisas que nos
trazem essas emoções à flor da pele
se você puder fechar seus olhos por um
tempo reservar um tempo para fechar os
olhos e pensar nas coisas que fazem você
se sentir essas emoções à flor da pele o
que seria isso
quais seriam essas coisas que te trazem
frio na barriga que trazem borboletas no
estômago que trazem arrepio
pode ser qualquer coisa pode ser cheio
de café domingo de manhã pode ser
barulho de lareira
numa noite fria pode ser o cheiro da
pessoa que você ama pode ser a sensação
de arrumar a mala para uma viagem com as
pessoas que você ama o que te faz sentir
vivo o que preenche a tua alma o que
traz essas emoções de borboletas no
estômago
eu costumo chamar essas sensações de
pequenos fragmentos de paraíso
porque são essas pequenas coisas que dão
sentido e que nos traz aquela sensação
maravilhosa de como é bom viver
principalmente se for perto das pessoas
que a gente chama porque as pessoas que
a gente ama dão sentido à isso elas
fazem tudo ou se todo o cenário fica
perfeito que vocês sabem qual é a única
coisa que te permite viver essa vida com
todas essas sensações com toda essa
plenitude de borboletas no estômago é o
fato de a gente ter saúde
saúde é o único bem que te dar de
presente essa vida com cheiro de café ou
com barulho de fogo com o cheiro da
pessoa que você ama porque sem ela as
coisas se desfaz em uma fração de
segundo
eu faço parte do grupo de pessoas que
sempre quis ser médica desde criança mas
quando estava fazendo faculdade de
medicina eu tive um momento de reflexão
de questionamento se aquilo que estava
fazendo era exatamente o que eu queria
fazer da minha vida porque eu tava
trabalhando com doença enquanto que eu
queria de fato era trabalhar com vida e
de acordo com que eu fui estudando
medicina eu fui percebendo que as
doenças que não fazem parte do grupo das
inevitáveis
elas poderiam ser evitadas se pelo menos
a gente tivesse ser questionado qual é a
vida que a gente quer viver
ao invés de a gente chegar onde eu
pensar o que a vida poderia ter sido
é quase como se fosse um trem com um
tíquete do trem que vai te levar a vida
dos seus sonhos com as pessoas que você
ama mas esse trem é só de ida
e esse tíquete requer consciência
responsabilidade e principalmente amor
porque é só com o amor que você vai ter
o auto cuidado que você precisa para
você poder viver a vida que você quer
perto das pessoas que você ama
segundo a oms as dez principais causas
de morte no mundo poderiam ser evitadas
poderiam ser evitadas se pelo menos a
gente tivesse a consciência do quanto a
gente quer viver nesse grupo das
inevitáveis
a gente não tem muita escolha mas a
responsabilidade de todas elas e dessas
dez principais são nossas e aí pra isso
eu resolvi recuperar a separar a saúde
em seis principais pontos para facilitar
lembrete para você embarcar nessa se
nessa escolha de vida
antes de tudo a gente precisa ter auto
cuidado auto cuidado é você reconhecer a
sua saúde é você escutar o teu corpo é
você percebeu que ele está te dizendo
sem auto cuidado a gente não percebe a
gente não nos persegue a gente não
percebe essa relação direta do nosso
corpo com a nossa saúde com o nosso bem
estar
é quase como se fosse aquela história do
avião que a gente tem que colocar a
máscara antes na gente e depois as
outras pessoas porque se a gente não
fizer isso a gente não vai perceber como
é que a gente está aí a gente não vai
estar pronto para fazer essas escolhas
se você quiser ouvir o nosso corpo ele
fala bem alto a alimentação
quando você pareça 6 é é 6 e 6 3
picos eu não queria que você tivesse na
tua cabeça algo engessado algo como
dieta ou algo com completamente
protocolado
eu quero que você enxerga sua saúde como
um ato de amor um ato de amor pra você
um ato de amor pelas pessoas com quem
você vive para as pessoas que você ama e
para as pessoas que te ama
quando a gente fala de alimentação isso
também é um ato de amor não é a idéia da
gente ter direta não é idéia da gente
não poder comer nada da gente comer
coisas sem sabor
a relação com a nossa comida ela tem que
ser olhar para a nossa comida e pensar o
quanto isso touch nutrindo é mais ou
menos aquilo que andré falou o quanto
aquilo que você está comendo nutrindo a
sua célula está nutrindo o teu corpo e
está fazendo você ser alguém melhor para
o mundo também vai muito além do que
fazer dieta e quando você olha para o
seu prato e percebe que aquilo que você
está comendo está nutrindo a célula está
te dando vida
quanto mais colorido for quanto mais
bem-estar aquilo que trouxer mais a sua
escolha vai dar certo e aí você não vai
precisar fazer dieta
se você seguir uma alimentação assim
você pode ficar tranquilo não vai ter
problema algum comentou hambúrguer na
sexta-feira ou alguma coisa e alguma
coisa diferente no final de semana assim
como um hambúrguer não vai estragar a
sua alimentação uma salada não vai
salvar também é o equilíbrio deles
o metabolismo o metabolismo a nossa
máquina né a perfeição que a gente tem
no nosso corpo
e quanto mais a gente cuida dele mas
essa máquina funciona bem
a gente precisa de muitas reações
bioquímicas fisiológicas hormonais e
metabólicas para fazer essa nossa nossa
máquina funciona bem e por isso o auto
cuidado porque através do auto cuidado e
da nossa percepção que a gente também
vai perceber o nosso metabolismo porque
ele fala muito é a única maneira da
gente entender como é que tá funcionando
essa máquina dentro da gente
se o metabolismo não está funcionando
bem essa máquina não vai funcionar bem
ea nossa saúde não vai ficar em
equilíbrio
então a gente precisa cuidar do nosso
metabolismo e não só quando a gente fica
doente é como é como fazer uma revisão
no carro só quando o carro está
estragado
não adianta a gente tem que fazer sempre
esse tipo de abordagem e de prevenção
para o nosso metabolismo saúde
intestinal
sim é verdade que o seu intestino é
assim o seu segundo cérebro
aliás ouso dizer que é um dos principais
órgãos do teu corpo enquanto a gente não
cuidar da nossa saúde intestinal
muita coisa vai passar despercebida é
ali que ele que a gente produz muitos
neurotransmissores ele que a gente
absorve todos aqueles nutrientes da
comida colorida que você resolveu comer
ou todas as toxinas de uma alimentação
completamente industrializada ou cheia
de toxinas
a gente precisa cuidar muito da nossa
saúde intestinal muita coisa começa a
ler a sua imunidade começa ali até a
defesa começa a ler e principalmente o
bem estar também porque muitas das
nossas substâncias que nos promove bem
estar também são produzidas no intestino
se eu pudesse dizer o mais importante
deles sem dúvida seria esse
a gente vive o mundo hoje a nossa vida
hoje em dia é como se a gente aguentar
se tudo como se a gente tivesse conta de
tudo
a gente dá conta de tudo às custas de
muita coisa aqui dentro
como que você tem manejado pelo estresse
como que você tem dado conta disso tudo
que você dá conta
só que a gente não vê o que está
acontecendo aqui dentro a gente não vê a
gente precisa ter um tempo para dar
conta desse estresse que a gente vive o
efeito que ele tem o nosso metabolismo é
até difícil explicar porque muitas vezes
é irreversível
a gente precisa tomar consciência disso
a vida que a gente vive hoje em dia ela
não não é equilibrada
portanto de estresse que a gente tem
isso tem impacto direto na nossa saúde
também e aí vem o repouso repouso é
quase como se fosse uma receita de vó
sabe aquela coisa quando a gente está
doente e aí falam kanjia banho cama a
gente precisa disso nas nossas vidas
a gente vive de novo achando que a gente
dá conta de tudo ea gente não dá
o repouso necessário para a nossa saúde
entrar em equilíbrio pra dar conta de
todo o resto repouso e descansar
a gente precisa cuidar do sono a gente
precisa cuidar do nosso bem estar
a gente precisa ter alguma válvula de
escape
se você tiver 30 minutos no seu dia
fazendo alguma coisa que te dê prazer e
que te faça bem você vai está modulando
bastante esse estresse você vai estar
descansando à cabeça mas é 30 minutos
focado em você não vale o celular e não
vale netflix tem que ser alguma coisa
que te faça bem que te dê prazer que td
bem estar porque a conta não fecha do
tanto que a gente tem trabalhado o tanto
que a gente tem diz cansado pra dar
conta do tanto que a gente tem que
trabalhar
a gente precisa cuidar muito de si
repouso porque é repouso demente repouso
de alma repouso físico mas a base disso
tudo
se eu pudesse resumir em uma palavra eu
fiz uma brincadeira de letras aqui
essa é a marca a gente precisa se amar
a gente precisa dar mais atenção para
quem a gente é a gente precisa dar mais
atenção para a nossa saúde e para o
nosso bem estar
porque é só se amando que a gente vai
ter o auto cuidado necessário para viver
a vida que a gente quer viver e não a
vida que poderia ter sido eu fiz essa
brincadeira de palavras pra gente se
lembrar porque é só assim que a gente
consegue um equilíbrio necessário para
viver a vida de hoje com muito amor
eu vi essa frase esses tempos do marcos
pg eu achei sensacional
a morte não é uma tragédia tragédia
quando a gente não viveu a saúde nos
coloca os melhores momentos das nossas
vidas
a vida que poderia ter sido
só vai depender de como você escolheu
viver e do amor que você dedicar a isso
e as pessoas que te amam e as pessoas
que você ama é isso
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]